>>Female Presenter: My name is Lauren Hannah-Murphy
and I'm really excited that we have our first
Filmmakers@Google event today.
And I'm really excited to introduce Doug Hannah,
who is my younger brother.
So I think it's safe to say I have known him
his whole life.
[laughter]
And from the moment that my Dad got his first
camcorder, he was making movies of one sort
or another.
Sometimes he was in front of the camera.
Sometimes, he was behind.
So, it's always been pretty obvious that he
was going to do something with film.
There was a short period of time when he had
me taping him as he would climb out from our
second floor and climb down the tree 'cause
he thought he wanted to be a stunt man.
But that didn't last too long.
[laughter]
And he went to school for Film and now has
been doing a lot of editing and film-making.
So, he's here today--without any of our home
videos, thankfully--but has his short film,
"Good News, Oklahoma!" and I'll let him introduce
that.
So, please join me in welcoming Doug Hannah.
[applause]
>>Doug Hannah: Thank you, guys.
That was a very good introduction.
Way more personal than any of the other introductions
I've had so far.
[laughter]
Well, thank you guys all for coming and watching
my short film.
We made this last year at the end of December.
So, this has been around for about a year.
We've been doing the festival circuits.
I think we've screened it at about nine film
festivals so far.
It won Best Comedy Short at the Atlanta Short
Fest, which was our first festival.
So right off the bat, it was really pretty
exciting.
I work for White Collar, which is a USA TV
show.
And the writer is also a writer for White
Collar.
And about at the end of Season Two, we were
talking about what we were gonna do during
our break.
And I was wanting to direct a short, 'cause
I'm trying to finagle my way out of editing,
since I'm getting sick of sitting in a dark
room all the time and getting into more of
the directing side of things.
And she had a few shorts and she pitched me
a couple ideas.
And she talked about this idea called "Good
News, Oklahoma!"
And instantly, I really knew I wanted to make
it.
I won't go too much into the plot now, since
we're about to watch it.
But I'm pretty addicted to news and watch
a lot of news and stuff.
And so, this was one of the reasons why I
wanted to make it.
And I'll go more into the other reasons why
I wanted to make it after you see it.
But yeah, I think I'll leave it at that.
Channing Powell is who wrote it--a really
talented writer.
And it was really fun getting to work with
her.
And if you're watching this online, it's just
gonna be a trailer.
I can't put the whole movie online 'cause
a lot of film festivals will only accept movies
that are not screened online.
They want it to have some type of premier
status more than anyone just being able to
watch it.
But all you guys can watch it now.
And then from here, we're going out to Denver
next weekend for the Festivus Film Festival.
So, we're excited about that.
But yeah.
Without further ado, here's a short film.
It's 18 minutes.
17:56.
[laughter]
It's called "Good News, Oklahoma!"
[plays film]
[happy music]
>>Sissy: I'm talking about a different kind
of news program.
One that doesn't sensationalize fear, but
promotes happiness.
I'm talking about a news program brought to
you by Sissy and Shaggy, your local alternative
news source.
>>Shaggy: Men from all over the country have
flooded the organization with their semen
donations.
>>Sissy: Truly an inspiring gift, Shaggy.
>>Shaggy: People really like good news.
[whistling music]
>>Tucker: Bad news, Oklahoma.
>>Barbara: Why would a news station with so-called
"good intentions" incite so much so-called
"bad behavior?"
>>Carl: You have to see this footage me and
[inaudible] uploaded to my laptop inside.
[glass shattering]
>>Birch: Amazing.
>>Barbara: Fuck me.
There's death of innocence on another network.
>>Sissy: It is our job to tell a story in
the face of adversity.
We're journalists.
>>Shaggy: I went to Business School.
>>Barbara: What you're saying is that Good
News, Oklahoma! is anti-American?
>>Ray: That's a good way to put it.
>>Sissy: If they're gonna yell at us, we're
gonna yell back louder.
>>Shaggy: Then how can anyone hear?
[Sissy sighs]
[crowd protests]
>>Sissy: Good News, Oklahoma!
Even violence isn't the answer.
[glass shatters]
[Sissy screams]
>>Tucker: Lesson learned.
[Barbara laughs]
>>Barbara: The hard way.
>>Birch: You're under contract.
>>Birch: We lose our right to pursue the American
Dreams, while suppressing your brothers.
>>Barbara: A good scoop.
That is a story.
We'll be back after these messages.
[loud movie music]
[end film clip]
[applause]
>>Doug Hannah: So, that was "Good News, Oklahoma!"
[laughter]
So, I like I said, we shot that back in December.
It was a five-day shoot.
We had two cameras.
We shot on the red.
>>FEMALE #1: What is that?
>>Doug Hannah: The red?
Yeah, I don't know if anyone follows it.
It's just a kind of camera.
A lot of the lower budget and actually, I
guess, more of the TV shows are using the
red now to shoot.
It gives a lot.
It has a sensor in it that shoots a very wide
range of everything.
So, it gives you a lot of control after in
post-production to really tweak the colors
and stuff.
And you can add shadows and make areas dark
and stuff like that.
Coming from an editorial standpoint, I get
a little geeky when it comes to the tech side
of stuff like that.
Oh, so I'll talk a little bit about--.
Like, "Good News, Oklahoma!"--its concept
and everything.
From the start, I get the question often of
how we chose Oklahoma.
And beside it just sounding good in the title,
"Good News, Oklahoma!" we obviously were thinking
of more conservative states in the US.
And the more research I was doing about it,
I found that Oklahoma was the only state where
during the 2008 election, every single district
had voted for McCain, which to me just seemed
crazy having grown up in Chicago, gone to
school in New York, and been living in California.
Everyone was obsessed of Obama.
So, to think of an entire state that just
wasn't interested in that seemed very different.
And so, I mean, it goes back and forth between
Oklahoma and Utah as being the two most conservative
states.
And so, "Good News, Oklahoma" sounds better
than "Good News, Utah," as well.
>>MALE #1: So does Park City, which rules.
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
Exactly.
So, that was part of the reason why we wanted
to make it was about Oklahoma.
And then when I had the script and was going
over it, I met someone from Oklahoma and I
explained to her the basic idea of it--a liberal
that makes everything that you just saw.
And she was just like, she thought I had to
make it, having grown up her entire life in
Oklahoma.
And her brother still lived out there and
was like, living in a town of 500 people.
And something that I always wondered was about
people that vote against their own interests,
kind of thing.
And so, her younger brother that still lives
there was talking to these people in the town
of 500 and slowly being like, "Oh, well if
you don't have health insurance, maybe you
should start voting a different way."
So, that was all fueling the fire for this.
Obviously, I didn't wanna make the short too
overtly political, though.
I think it's really easy to make something
that has all your ideas and beliefs in it.
And then, people get really turned off by
it very quickly 'cause then they just see
it as a liberal movie.
So, we took a lot of the jokes out.
Originally, there was some jokes about broad
stereotypes about Tea Partiers and stuff like
that.
And we focused a little more.
So, it was a little more accessible for everybody
so people would just take it for the entertainment
value and not feel like they're being attacked.
>>FEMALE #2: How has that gone over?
>>Doug Hannah: It's actually gone--.
I was gonna say is we showed it at the Tulsa
Film Fest and on the right over there, I'm
sitting on the flight and I'm sitting next
to a guy who's from Oklahoma, who had never
been on a plane before.
And he was freaking out and telling me to
talk to him the whole time.
And in my head I'm thinking, "Oh, my God.
What did I get myself into?"
But no one, like--.
But I showed it to everyone.
I've given people that go to a festival--a
film festival--are obviously a little more
artistic, maybe liberal, you could say.
I think I'm stereotyping, but everyone was
really open and didn't feel like they're being
attacked as being from Oklahoma or anything
like that.
And if anything related to it and wanted to
know where we got actors that had Oklahoma
accents and stuff.
Which leads me to the next thing is that we
did film this in LA.
We lucked out, or didn't luck out, where the
week were filming in December, it was raining
the entire week.
So, that's why all the exterior's , all kinda
gray and stuff, which actually helped us out
a lot.
One palm tree snuck in there.
I don't know if anyone caught it.
[laughter]
It's just in the background outside of the
house.
He walks by a palm tree.
I think that kinda covers it.
Maybe I'll open it up to questions.
Yeah.
Does anyone have any questions?
I'll--.
>>MALE #2: How long was the shoot itself?
>>Doug Hannah: Oh, yeah.
The shoot was five days.
I completed the whole thing.
It is about four months.
I probably could've gotten it done in three.
It's one of those things with any short film,
if you ever talk to a director, they'll take
up as much time as they have.
So, if I had five months, it would've been
five months.
But if I had six, it would've probably taken
me six.
[Doug Hannah coughs]
But a five-day shoot.
It was pretty good.
The script--the original script--was 25 pages.
So, we were shooting about five or six pages
a day.
If you compare that to White Collar, which
our scripts on that show are,
I think, about 50 to 55 pages and they shoot
those in seven days.
So, there, they're shooting about anywhere
from six and a half to ten, eleven pages a
day.
But that's, obviously, with a full professional
crew.
We did have a crew of about 35 people, which
for an independent short for this was really
good.
And it was just one of those things where
since we were shooting with two cameras, all
of a sudden our camera department was really
big.
And then because of that, it just--.
Everything built on top of it.
Any other questions?
>>MALE #3: How did you finance it?
>>Doug Hannah: Me and the writer really just
wanted to make it.
And so, we just split it.
[Doug Hannah laughs]
Yeah.
And called in every favor of everyone I've
ever worked with.
Our producer was amazing.
She was--.
She's an actress out in LA and she'd been
working out there for like, 15 years.
And so, the majority of the actors were all
cast just through friends of hers that are
all working actors.
A lot of those guys do a lot of commercials.
So you might recognize them from random commercials
here and there.
>>MALE #4: So they gave you good rates?
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
[laughter]
The best rate that they could possibly give,
which was free.
Yeah, exactly.
The actors were all amazing.
We really lucked out on--.
Myself, coming from an editing background
and into directing,
I had the misconception of like, "Oh, well
I watch performances all day long and choose
the good ones."
So I thought, "I'll know if they have a good
performance 'cause I'm used to watching it."
And then I got on set and it was like--.
When you're creating something from scratch,
it's totally different than when I'm just
sitting in my little edit bay watching performances.
And that's something I've been working on
now with taking acting classes and stuff.
But I hadn't done it at the time.
But really was lucky to have such good actors
that they were able to do the script analysis
and really know what was going on.
And I think they all did a really fantastic
job and really understood the tone of the
whole movie and did a great job.
>>MALE #5: So, what motivates them to do it
for free?
>>Doug Hannah: Um.
I was wondering the same thing.
And talking to my friend, it's like, actors,
they just wanna act.
And like Sarayu, who was our lead, unfortunately
in Hollywood it's hard for an Indian actress
to be the lead of stuff.
I mean, she's constantly working.
She's a really great actress.
But she was a series regular on "Sons of Tucson,"
and that was one of the few spots where they
had a leading Indian woman.
But it's not very common.
And then the other ones--.
It was just a fun script.
It actually said something as opposed to just
being about nothing, which I guess is often
the case.
So, yeah.
It was really nice of them.
>>MALE #6: So, it seemed like you're targeting
both the over sensationalism side of news
and the right-wing slant.
And I'm wondering if you could tease out what
percent of the target is.
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
The original script was pretty 50/50.
And I had decided I wanted it to lean more
to the news aspect of it.
And then, the kind of right-wing stuff that
was more of just like what was going on, I
wanted that to be more of the backdrop and
less of what the movie was about.
Like I said, I didn't really wanna feel like
anyone was being attacked, except sensationalized
news, which is more of a thing than a person.
And yeah.
Like I said before, I'm pretty obsessed with
news.
I watch probably more news than is healthy
for me, to the point where when I'm just traveling
out of the country and came back and they're
still talking about the same stuff, like with
the Republican Primaries and stuff, I realized
that life goes on.
[laughter]
>>MALE #7: Have you had any feedback from
people who work in newsrooms?
>>Doug Hannah: Not really, actually.
No.
That's what I was thinking.
No one really has said much.
I don't know how many people have seen it
from the news side of stuff, which is interesting.
Yeah?
>>MALE #8: Was 18 minutes-- is that the expectation
from the festival circuit?
Is that--?
>>Doug Hannah: It's long.
>>MALE #8: It just felt natural from the script,
or--?
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
Eighteen minutes is long for a short and it
struggles to get into festivals.
The ideal time for a short to screen at festivals
would be like, seven minutes, because they
try to put as many short films together in
a 120-minute program.
So, if they take my film, then that's two
or three shorts that they're not able to put
in.
The script was 25 pages.
So typically, it's a minute per page.
So, the first cut was about 22, 23 minutes.
And then we just start cutting.
Tried to get it as short as possible.
We had to cut down to 15 minutes at one point.
But then it was just like, pssh.
Stuff was flying by and there was no moment
to breathe or really know what was going on.
We had cut that scene--the nighttime scene--where
they're talking in the kitchen thing with
the Chinese food, which kind of explains what's
going on and it gives you a moment to breathe.
Because everything else is just coming right
at you, which was a choice to have everything
else moving really fast 'cause I wanted to
have that feeling of the news, the fast-moving
of that type of stuff.
And that was one of the reasons why we shot
with two cameras, 'cause we had a ton of camera
angles.
So, I was able to, when editing, keep the
pace going pretty fast.
So even though it is 18 minutes, I think it
feels shorter--maybe like ten minutes hopefully.
[laughter]
That's my argument to any film festivals.
Yeah.
>>MALE #9: I'm curious what the dynamic is
like for you watching your movie in a room
with people who have never seen it before.
Like, did they laugh at the right--?
[laughter]
Or had there been things where you expected
it to be felt one way and it wasn't?
Or--?
>>Doug Hannah: It's always really refreshing
'cause I'm definitely my worst critic.
So, it's like, one editor explains it to me.
Whenever I edit any episode--this film especially--I
know where all the dead bodies are hidden,
meaning I know all the little cheats I did.
I know all the bad stuff that was there that
I cut out.
So, it's like watching something, it's sometimes
really painful.
But watching it with an audience is really
refreshing and nice.
And I say, "Oh, there is a joke there.
It is funny."
>>MALE #9: You don't think anybody spotted
the palm tree?
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
No one spotted the palm tree.
Exactly.
Yeah, so no.
It's always really nice to watch.
I mean, this isn't quite huge, but it's always
fun for me to see it on the big screen like
that.
It's pretty cool.
Yeah, in the back.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #10: So, not knowing
much about the film industry, I'm curious
what you do to maximize viewership of an 18-minute
film?
I think a bunch of things.
There's traditional distribution routes.
There's putting it up on YouTube and making
money off the ads.
You do what Louis CK did and just make a free
download and sell your movie for like, three
bucks or whatever.
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
>>MALE : #10: I really enjoyed it.
I'd love to be able to get other people seeing
it, but short of doing some research to figure
out which film festival it'll be at next,
I don't know how to help you with your art.
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah, yeah.
Well, that's a great question.
[laughter]
I guess I'll take the long answer to get there.
The original goal of making it, despite wanting
to make it, was just for my own practice as
an editor trying to be a director.
And then the next step was I was getting it
out there.
And so the festival route was just a way to
get it in front of as many big audiences possible.
And unfortunately, because I'm going the festival
route, I can't put it online yet.
That's like a clause that pretty much every
festival is, it can't be online anywhere.
So I mean, we're gonna be wrapping up the
whole festival circuit around October of this
year.
And then I guess I'll start thinking of the
next thing of how to get it out to an even
bigger audience.
>>MALE #11: It's movie channels like HBO or
Showtime?
>>Doug Hannah: Like IFC or stuff like that.
They show shorts, but most of the time it's
ones that have gone on to win Sundance and--
>>MALE #11: OK.
>>Doug Hannah: which we're not quite at that
level unfortunately.
So I guess the answer would be just please
stand by--
[Doug Hannah laughs]
and it will be out online come October.
It'll be more widely available.
It is online now, but you have to know a password.
And maybe if you come by after, I'll tell
you it.
[laughter]
>>MALE #12: Is there a list of where it will
be screened?
>>Doug Hannah: The next one is next weekend
in Denver, like I said.
And then after that, we're still waiting to
hear from about I think like, 20 more fests,
possibly.
We submitted to about 60.
>>FEMALE #3: [inaudible]
>>Doug Hannah: It's been an eight so far.
>>MALE #13: And you have to pay to get yourself
there from those, or--?
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah, technically, to get to
the festivals and stuff.
And just depending on the festival.
Some get you out there.
Some put you up.
A whole variation of stuff.
Yeah?
>>MALE #14: The comment you said about to
some extent about being a director.
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
>>MALE #14: Do you like that it was great
practice?
Like, do you feel like you're in a better
spot now to do something else, and you have
other projects now because of this?
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
Absolutely.
It was great practice.
It definitely showed me my weaknesses, which
was working with actors.
[chuckles]
And so, I've been able to take a proactive
approach to it then.
Now I'm taking lots of classes and that type
of stuff and talking to more actors and that
type of stuff.
And yeah, I learned a ton.
My producer would always give me a hard time.
I'd be like, "Oh, let's try this line or that
size lines.
No, wait.
Maybe let's switch.
OK.
Let's switch back."
She'd say, "Oh, first time director."
[laughter]
And poked me a little bit.
So, just as much practice as possible.
I've been shadowing a lot directors on other
hour-long dramas, one's that I've edited episodes
of, just to get as much experience on set
as possible.
Having edited, I have that whole side of it
locked down right.
I know angles.
I know what I need at this point, but it's
more of the on-set, day-to-day stuff.
And then in terms of future projects, there's
a whole bunch of ideas, writers I've been
talking to.
And the plan is I edit a pilot for the same
creator as White Collar in March, and then
I go on to do the next season of White Collar.
Then, I’ll have time off again in October.
So I'm hoping to prep something while I'm
working and then shoot something hopefully
next October--another short.
And then go from there.
Any other questions?
Yes.
>>MALE #15: Yeah.
So I guess this is a piggy-back on Seth's
comment earlier of do they laugh at the right
time and whatnot.
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
>>MALE #15: And I think probably what I wanna
say was the audience fairly different in many
different ways?
Who would you describe as your target customer?
Every movie is a piece of your advertising
you're selling to someone.
In this regard, to box offices.
You didn't have the luxury of a big production
studio--
>>Doug Hannah: Mm-hmm.
>>MALE #15: working behind you.
You did some research and said, "This is what
the people of America want right now."
How do figure that out and how is it hard
at making a short as an independent filmmaker
to know is this gonna be funny to everyone
or is just my group of 25 working on this
that's gonna think it's hilarious?
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
Yeah.
I guess ultimately, we wanted to open it up
to everybody.
And that's why I was sensitive when it came
like poking fun at Tea Partiers or something
like that, or liberals or conservatives or
whatever.
And I just wanted everyone to enjoy it.
As in the specific age, I guess I can't--.
Ultimately, I wanted everyone to love it.
But I mean, it was based off of my sensibility,
so it's probably gonna be more geared younger--not
to say that only young people will get it.
But for example, my mom watched it and she
just watched it with a friend of hers and
she didn't get that it was a comedy.
[laughter]
>>MALE #16: It was a tragedy?
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
She said that she didn't like the swears in
it.
[laughter]
So, that's something that I don't always think
about, that excluding people just by having
the F-word in it a bunch of times and that
people will tune out because they don't like
that type of language.
And that's hard for me to remember.
But it's something that now I'm more aware
of.
But yeah.
So I guess ultimately, I hope everyone will
get it, but I realize that not everyone will.
>>MALE #17: Was there a trade-off where you
realized that between different demographics
you're going to do different themes--
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
>>MALE #17: and was it pretty hard to make
a movie if you want it perfect to your passion
it's gonna appeal to all those demographics
and like sector-graphics?
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
Ultimately, I just feel like I have to make
a move that I myself get.
And I have to play to my sensibilities 'cause
if I'm trying to make a movie for 60-year
olds, I'm not gonna be able to do it.
I just don't--.
I could think I know what they would want,
but ultimately, I would probably be way off
I would think.
Maybe.
Maybe I'm not giving myself enough credit,
but it's just not what I'm comfortable with
working in.
Yeah?
>>FEMALE #4: So again, not being at all familiar
with the industry, and now hearing you talk
about taking a script and making choices,
can you describe in a little more detail your
role, what you were personally doing and responsible
for and a little bit what your day-to-day
looks like?
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
Totally.
And if I use words that seem a little out
there, it's--.
Like my sister said in the introduction, I've
been doing this stuff since I was like 15,
seriously.
So sometimes I use terminology that I don't
even realize is "in" terminology.
But I'm just used to using it.
So, as a director starting with the script,
when I first got it, I first just read it
just to enjoy it.
But after that, it's like, "All right.
Which parts were working for me?
Which parts weren't totally working?
What did I get?
What parts didn't I really get?"
And then I started just by asking questions
of the writer.
What were we meaning here?
Could we try maybe something here?
And then, as it got shaped more specifically,
I was adding jokes.
I just wanted to add more to the comedy.
And then further along, as I started going
through the script and deciding camera angles
and really looking at transitions of how are
we getting from this scene to the next scene.
And so it was at that point where for example,
I knew I was gonna wanna come out of TV monitors,
go across, and go into the next monitor.
And I thought that would be a real organic
way to get from one scene to another.
So, I then had her add lines to help cover
those transitions--those little bumpers, "Up
next on OK Action News."
I had her add those.
Actually, we had about a page and a half and
at the end of that shoot day, we just had
them stand next to each other and go through
and do all of them.
Yeah, do all of them.
And I knew I was gonna probably wanna sprinkle
that throughout.
At that point I didn't exactly know where
I was gonna put 'em.
I just knew I wanted some extra material.
>>FEMALE #4: That whole editor perspective.
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
So, that's part of the script-writing, but
in terms of like, how the words were spoken,
the whole structure, she really was instrumental
in that.
And I was trying to cut the script down 'cause
I wanted as many days to shoot as little as
possible.
So I was like, "Oh, do we really need that?
Do we need that?"
And for example, I was I guess, really wanting
her to cut that nighttime scene.
I was like, "We don't need it.
We have all this information already."
And she really fought for it.
And then as it turns out, we needed that scene
really badly.
Otherwise, the whole pace--I think people
just wouldn't even understand what the movie
was about without it.
And so, it was that writer mentality more
that I'm lacking in experience that helped
a lot.
>>MALE #18: So, does the writer hate you now?
[laughter]
>>Doug Hannah: No, she does not hate me, luckily.
>>MALE #18: [inaudible ]
>>Doug Hannah: Wait for her Q and A and maybe
she'll say differently.
No, she's very good with notes and I think
working in professional, hour-long dramas,
you have to be good with taking creative criticism
or constructive criticism.
And then just going onto the set, it's choosing
the angles with your DP and then honing the
performances in.
Oh, Director of Photography, with whoever
is shooting it.
>>MALE #19: You said two cameras, so there's
two people operating cameras, plus a DP.
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
And then in addition to that, there's two
focus pullers.
So, the camera operators don't even deal with
the focus.
So per camera, there's two people.
And then the DP is--the Director of Photography--is
with me at the monitors, watching two of the
monitors.
So you have your A-camera and B-camera.
So, you're watching both at the same time,
which is nice 'cause then you can do cross-coverage
of the actors that are improvising and stuff.
You have close-ups on both of them.
Although, we were sharing--.
We had two cameras, but one lens package.
Meaning, we couldn't just zoom in like on
a video camera, your different sized lenses.
And to cut costs, we were only using one lens
package.
So, we couldn't ever do two close-ups the
exact same size since we didn't have two of
the same lenses.
Yeah.
>>MALE #20: So you said that you needed the
scene at night and stuff.
Did you try a different version of the movie,
different version of the short with different
audiences to see how they reacted to the scene,
the life of the scene?
>>Doug Hannah: If I had more time, I probably
would've started doing that, showing it to
bigger audiences.
A film I had done in college was a documentary
and I showed it to a lot of people and got
a lot of notes.
And I found my head just got clouded where
I didn't even know which notes to listen to
and which notes not to listen to at that point.
So with this film, I took a different approach
and really kept it very small where I just
only had maybe a dozen people all together
look at it--people I've worked with and stuff
like that.
And I really kept the creative part of the
editing only took two weeks, so the first
week I did my cut, showed it to some people,
did some notes, showed it to a couple more
people, did a few more notes.
I knew I would keep editing it for months
and months if I kept showing it to more and
more people.
So, I kept it small, closed it, and said,
"All right.
Time to move on."
So I wasn't really trying to respond to a
lot of different people's ideas.
Yeah?
>>MALE #21: What was the total amount of footage
recorded between the two cameras that you
had cut down to, ultimately, the 18 minutes?
>>Doug Hannah: I don't totally know.
I would guess I was probably shooting about
three hours a day.
So, probably about 15 hours of footage.
I wasn't doing a ton of takes.
I was probably doing about two or three takes
per set-up, meaning for each size, each position
where the camera was in, up to three times
like that.
But we were moving pretty fast.
We were trying to really stick to that TV
schedule of just going and going.
>>MALE #22: So for one scene, you would then
shoot it with several different camera set-ups?
>>Doug Hannah: Exactly.
So, every time I go to a different angle,
every time it cuts, I shot from that angle
for the entire scene most of the time, even
if I only go to it for two seconds, three
seconds or whatever.
I have that option of going to it whenever.
Yeah?
>>MALE #23: What's the role of a producer?
>>Doug Hannah: Good question.
There's tons of different kinds of producers
and it can mean a whole bunch of things.
For the case of this short, our producer was
anything we needed, she was helping coordinate.
So, our casting calls, our location.
She was negotiating with the owners of those
locations of how much we would spend on it.
Our camera rentals, hiring all our crew.
It was really a huge job to undertake.
It's more of like the managerial side, I guess
you could say.
But it's still creative because you're still
doing those creative choices, just in a more
managerial standpoint I guess.
That would be like a line producer.
An executive producer sometimes just oversees
it all more, supplies the money sometimes.
It can mean a whole bunch of things.
Yeah?
>>MALE #24: So at the end it's something in
an author of production.
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
>>MALE #24: Did you form a production company
for this?
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
We kinda just formed it just so when we were
signing out and renting equipment and stuff.
>>MALE #24: Is that normal for a short like
this to form a company?
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
Since it was my first one, we just--.
We were like, "Hannah-Powell Productions."
We just put it together really fast since
we on such a tight schedule.
At this point I have a production company
now that's actually incorporated and everything.
So for the future, I'll use that.
But this one, we just put it together really
fast.
Opened a business bank account and started
going.
Yeah?
>>MALE #25: Do you plan to just stick to shorts?
>>Doug Hannah: No.
Ideally, I'd wanna do a feature.
It's just obviously more money, more time.
And I do hope to get to that point shortly.
We just--.
I feel like one more short would be good for
me.
Just one more time to practice with actors,
use some of the techniques I've been learning
in my directing classes and stuff like that,
unless a feature option came my way.
[laughter]
But it just seems like another, just one more
short just to knock it out quickly.
And then, before I tackle a feature.
But a feature would be a ton of fun to do.
>>MALE #25: Do these tend to be like your
resume for the people who are thinking about
hiring directors?
>>Doug Hannah: Yeah.
Hopefully though this, a show that I edit
or something will bring me on and I can negotiate
an episode to direct from this.
And at least I have, then, stuff under my
belt.
It's nice now that I have a short, I can say
I am a director as opposed to "I want to direct."
At least I've done something.
Is there any other questions?
No one wants to go to work?
Well, thank you guys so much.
It was great.
Thank you.
[applause]